lr le feuilleton sans fin c'est le thème
de notre débat j'accueille pascal
perrineau bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
politologue professeur à sciences po
chargé d'ailleurs par le parti
républicain d'analyser cette
consultation il est dit frédéric dabi
bonsoir bienvenue à vous directeur
général opinion de l'ifop c'est votre
institut qui a mené cette enquête vous
nous expliquerez jean sébastien ferjou
bonsoir jean sébastien bienvenus vous
êtes le directeur de la publication du
site atlantico et j'accueille allemand
laetitia club pas d'éditorial east de
sens public tous les mardis et jeudis
bienvenue aux hôtes vous retrouver
laëtitia vous avez entendu la la fin du
reportage de femmes hier et caire un
conclave ça nous a fait sourire c'est
peut-être la solution mais ce serait pas
bon signe pour xavier bertand vous
connaissez le dicton sur les conclaves 1
qui entre pape au conclave en sort en
sort cardinal pascal mérigeau c est ce
qu on peut quand même dire que c'est un
peu lui le favori le pape a mis les
écouter quand on regarde cette enquête
qui a été fait et réalisé par l'ifop
auprès de 15000 personnes représentant
l'électorat de la droite et du centre on
s'aperçoit que au fond il ya trois
candidats qui existe vraiment michel
barnier sur un mode un peu plus mineures
que valérie pécresse et que xavier
bertrand mais quand il s'agit pour les
électeurs de celui ou de celle qui
serait capable d'inviter la droite au
second tour est de battre ou bien
emmanuel macron ou bien marine le pen là
de manière claire c'est xavier bertrand
qui domine qui dominent le jeu mais on
voit bien dans ses hésitations si vous
voulez que voilà que c'est difficile de
choisir un candidat à la présidentielle
quand il n'ya plus de candidat naturel
et bâti a plus d'homme ou de femme avec
un charisme qui s'impose en plus dense
et voilà c'était ça la blessure est
important et c'était la meilleure
solution certainement mais n'est pas de
gaulle qui veut ou même sarkozy qui veut
même si c'était un charisme et un
leadership plus faible bien sûr que
celui du général de gaulle et donc on
voit des hommes et des femmes qui
hésitent le conclave entendu parler du
conclave
l'auto proclamation ça se pratique
beaucoup par les temps qui courent une
meilleure donc je vous le dis puis je
tente de nouer un dialogue direct avec
la population
une primaire fermée aux fonds les
adhérents qui décide quels cas
d'ailleurs dans plusieurs états
américains dans une dizaine d'amis
d'état américain s'est pas la primaire
ouverte ces dépôts ce sont les primaires
fermées et puis les primaires plus ou
moins ouvertes d'ailleurs parce qu'il
peut y avoir des primaires très ouverte
on ratisse très large puis des primaires
semi ouverte ou en effet on détermine
une liste d'électeurs qui acceptent de
s'engager formellement dans le choix des
candidats c'est pour ça je disais la
bouteille à l'encré n'a pas fini et
c'est quand même un processus lourd ça
fait partie des thèmes dont on va parler
je vous donnerai évidemment la parole
tout à l'heure pascal perrineau on a on
a quarante minutes dans dans chacun de
nos débats c'est c'est un luxe autant
profite ici sur public sénat frédéric
dabi et jouez comme vous nous disiez à
mouthe cette enquête c'est assez inédit
quand même donc pascal perrineau l'a dit
quinze mille personnes se disant de
droite ou ayant voté à droite un
échantillon choisi sur un échantillon
général on parle d'abord comme on parle
ce qui a pas de données je dirais à fait
statistics ousmane dabo graphique sur le
pôle de droite on est parti d'un
échantillon classique d'un sondage sauf
qu'ils n'étaient pas faits auprès de
1000 personnes dans des zones comme dans
les angles de passes icm auprès de
trente mille personnes une mini france
qui a été constituée et à partir de là
on a extrait le peuple de droite le
terme de peuple de droite content parce
que ce ne sont pas que des sympathisants
de droite y avait aussi des personnes
qui allaient voter à droite à la
présidentielle aux européennes y de
quelques uns quand même aux élections
régionales y en a eu beaucoup et puis
parce que ça ne suffisait pas dans un
contexte d'abstention si forte on apprit
également sur les questions classiques
de l'ifop de positionnement sur un axe
gauche droite dépasse homme qui était au
centre droit c'est à dire que maintenant
il serait peut-être tentés par un vote
macron des personnes à droite et des
personnes très à droite peut-être tentés
par un vote marine le pen ou elysee
monde donc c'est vraiment le peuple de
droite et il est peut-être plus ouverts
en termes de sociologie que l'électorat
de la primaire de 2016 qui était plus
composé de sympathisants même s'il y
avait quelques personnes de gauche et
d'un électorat plus cheap et ce sous
démographiquement et c'est vrai comme
l'a dit pascal perrineau à partir de
cette enquête on voit un avantage assez
nette en faveur de xavier bertrand
notamment sur la dimension
tjx c'est le seul qui peut battre marine
le pen c'est le seul qui peut battre
emmanuel macron c'est le seul qui
apparaît en position d'être au second
tour là pendant à nous parler on voyait
pardon nous interromprons voit le
dossier sur le la perception l'opinion
avait une opinion favorable ces chiffres
là c'est très équilibré très très
équilibré on a vraiment deux fêtes
personnalités qui font trou xavier
bertrand valérie pécresse notons que les
chiffres ne sont pas énormes 53 52 % ça
monte je crois 78 % chez les
sympathisants et l'air n'oublions pas
aussi quelque chose de très simple on a
posé je dirais l'indicateur de base on
les connaît on ne les connais pas une
personne de droite sur cinq déclarent ne
pas connaître vraiment saviez bertrand
et valérie pécresse on est loin des 99%
de nicolas sarkozy de françois fillon ou
d'alain juppé alors on dit pas en étant
cellex c est une primaire de second
couteau je trouve que c'est un mais des
plus tôt inappropriée mais quand même ce
ne sont pas des personnes qui se sont
des personnes malgré leur ancienneté
dans le champ politique qui vont devoir
faire un travail de rencontres avec des
français pendant la campagne s'ils vont
au bout et donc je voulais se terminer à
la démonstration parce que je voulais
vraiment qu'on conçoit qu'on cadre avec
l'infographie qui ont regardé mais
effectivement quand on se projette sur
un second tour là il ya un bonus garder
oui alors c'est le reflet des enquêtes
d'opinion beaucoup de personnes de
droite ont vu que c'est le seul qui bat
et marine le pen et même à comps et
aussi le fait de l'histoire de la droite
ça fait quand même deux élections
présidentielles perdues de suite
clairement il ya un sentiment d'urgence
et de fébrilité chez beaucoup de
sympathisants de droite qui ne sont pas
tentés par un vote macron par un vote le
pen comment gagner dans un contexte
pareil où la procédure n'est pas
complètement connu donc cette fébrilité
se voit pour l'instant on a envie de
choisir celui de donner le plus sûr qui
pourrait gagner ce n'est pas encore fait
jean sébastien ferjou comment vous
peut-être sur xavier bertrand a ensuite
on ira peut-être c'est évidemment sur
michel barnier on parlera jamais sur
xavier bertrand comment vous l'analysez
ce sondage cette enquête on peut parler
d' enquête mais comme ce qui vient
d'être exposé sa version résonne
aujourd'hui xavier bertrand est un petit
peu avantagé maintenant il n'a pas plié
le match n'a pas réellement construit
deux dynamiques malgré tout c'est le
premier à se déclarer avant même les
régionales au printemps dernier il n'a
pas véritablement imposé sa marque en
politique tout effet de dynamique et
puis il est en quelque sorte dans une
posture qui devient de plus en plus
difficiles à déchiffrer c'est à dire une
primaire il veut pas mais se soumettre
au vote d'un congrès il veut bien il ne
veut à aucun prix d'inde et partage
ouvert mais il veut bien éventuellement
venir voir les parlementaires aient
l'air pour leur dire vous êtes ma
famille et quoi qu'il en soit je ne
ferai rien contre cette famille là et
donc on sait plus bien si longue la
démonstration de force dans une
démonstration de faiblesse ils voulaient
sur deux de désigner quoi bon lire en
creux c'est quand même c'est quand même
un aveu de faiblesse c'est quand même de
reconnaître c'est une chose que de
s'auto proclamer comme le disait pascal
perrineau c'en est une autre que de
constater qu'on y parvient ou non est
certes les républicains sur la partie
était très dévitalisées parce que s'il
ne manque pas juste de chef il manque
deux chats parce qu'ils n'ont plus
véritablement de l'adn idéologie
concluent ils savent pas bien qu'ils
sont sur l'europe sur l'économie sur le
capitalisme sur y compris d'ailleurs sur
des sujets comme l'immigration donc il
est difficile pour quelqu'un d'émerger
face à un parti qui est aussi perdu en
revanche ils tiennent quand même un
certain nombre de deux points cruciaux
comme une commission d'investiture parce
que l'ancien candidature en soit vous
avez une personnalité ensorcelante comme
eric zemmour et madame macron peut-être
ou cendres l onction gens c'est dans un
autre registre vous trouvez les gens à
l'improviste oui non mais non mais vous
trouvez des gens qui peuvent être prêt à
se faire tuer pour vous peut-être plus
facilement parce que votre père votre
charisme les attire si vous êtes un peu
moins ça comme peut-être xavier bertrand
valérie pécresse ou michel barnier le
son vous avez besoin de pouvoir
promettre quelque chose donc à poste de
ministre messi va de victoire elle
paraît lointaine et à tout prendre même
du point de vue de quelqu'un de droite -
évidence qu'une victoire d'emmanuel
macron vous hésitez le lot de
consolation c'est un poste parlementaire
mais quand vous n'avez pas la commission
d'investiture et ni l'un ni l'autre
enfin dans la commission d'investiture
difficile c'est pour ça que je pense
qu'il ya quand même une petite surprise
dans ce sondage là michel barnier on l'a
très peu vu il me semble que l' enquête
a été fait fin août et des grosses
sorties médiatiques de michel barnier
c'est quand même elle est là sur quinze
jours mais comme vous le disiez en
entendu à 7 ans on est quand même dans
une phase essentielle sont assez loin de
la politique je pense qu'il ya une
petite surprise barnier dans un
environnement de confusion idéologique
le critère de la stature et peut-être
celui qui à l'arrivée contre le plus
parce que ce que vous demandez si vous
dites façon ils savent pas trop ce
qu'ils pensent où je n'arrive pas à
comprendre ce qu'il pense je veux celui
qu'un radar qui voient derrière le haut
de la colline donc le critère de la
stature il est loin d'être à négliger
rien n'est joué mais je pense quand même
qu'il ya une petite dynamique michel
barnier alors laetitia cru pas que ce
sondage comment vous le vous le persée
ne percevez vous demandez un peu à quoi
il sert oui je me suis demandé à quoi ça
servait parce que j'imagine déjà
la question
j'ai pas vous demander frédéric combien
ça a coûté mais il me semble que c'est
très onéreux ce type
voilà sur 15000 personnes sur quinze
jours j'imagine le coup alors si c'est
pour soulager
un peu les mots m11x de christian jacob
qui finalement ne veut pas de cette
primaire bon bah ça le rassure un petit
peu puisque apparemment les sondés sont
plutôt favorables à un congrès où on
pourrait inclure xavier bertrand très
bien mais enfin il me semble que pour le
résultat c'est à dire que là on vient de
faire un tour de table résultat c'est
une tête pour davance pour xavier
bertrand
résultat qu'on a par ailleurs dans
toutes les autres enquêtes toutes les
semaines passent et à dire que c'est
quand même des personnalités qui s'en
sont sondés et quand je dis toutes les
semaines je pense que c'est même plus
d'une fois par semaine vous voyez donc
finalement très honnêtement je ne
comprends pas à part soulagé un peu
voilà les les questionnements de
christian jacob rassurer les troupes se
dira on a potentiellement un gagnant
xavier bertrand est encore thomas
imaginons que le congrès ne ne
choisissent pas
imaginons que ce soit valérie pécresse
mais il va quand même y aller que saviez
bertrand donc on repart au point zéro du
problème à droite donc on voit bien
qu'ils aient effectivement emmanuel
macron il me semble à complètement
siphonnés c'est quand même une bonne
photographie de l'électorat de droite à
l'instant t est interdite mais non mais
ça on est tout à fait d'accord mais à
l'instant chez nous sommes nous sommes
au mois de septembre donc avec quelle
efficacité encore une fois ce que c'est
ma question de départ c'est-à-dire que
si encore une fois on a le même résultat
que partout ailleurs je ne vois pas à
quoi ça sert si on n'a pas testé cette
hypothèse de une valérie pécresse
désignée ou un michel barnier désigné et
peut-être oui ou non est ce que xavier
bertrand et là il me semble que oui et
juste pour un peu nuancer je vous
rappelle quand même les sondages vous
allez détester un frédéric mais désolé d
pour les élections régionales
d'accord rappelez vous on nous annonçait
un raz-de-marée pour le rn on nous
annonçait la veille de du premier tour
cinq à six régions non pour le
rassemblement pour le rassemblement
national ça faisait la une du parisien
et on nous annonçait un thierry mariani
grand vainqueur il ya eu zéro région
pour l'intérêt et un taux d'abstention
record non je dis ce qu'il faut nuancer
ce genre on a bien compris comment ça
manque un peu de nuance au papier mhr
laetitia non ce n'est pas une enquête
comme une autre déjà vous dit assez
justement il ya des sondages toutes les
semaines sur des sondages faits auprès
de 1000 personnes et ce sont des
intentions de vote là avec pascal
perrineau on a refusé de faire la sauce
ou le vote ou du potentiel électoral ce
n'était pas le rôle et le statut d'un
sondage de dire il faut désigner x y ou
z et on a plutôt travaillé et
qualitativement sur des traits d'image
les territoires d'image qui font partie
de la panoplie présidentielle quand même
quinze mille personnes ça fait un
échantillon absolument énorme ça réduit
la marge d'erreur à quasiment zéro ça
permet de travailler pour parler un peu
jargon sur les tris où les résultats
croisés on pourrait rester six à neuf
mois surtout le bout qui fait 300 ou 400
et puis n'y avait pas que ces questions
sur les traits d'image il y avait un
retour sur la primaire de 2016 ces
personnes aura le temps d'en parler on a
un regard qui est très ambivalents et
distanciée à des sympathisants de droite
et puis avait également les enjeux
qu'elles ont joué là autant il ya des
choses qui peuvent s'y sont très
volatils qui peuvent bouger en quelques
semaines autant ce conte dans le coeur
et des reins le peuple de droite sur les
enjeux qui vont compter pour l'élection
présidentielle c'est une aide à la
décision qui peut être intéressante pour
les républicains et pour le vent pluie
cette enquête a été finalement
publiciser donc ce sera un outil c'est
salut c'est là que vous intervenez
pascal perri douce est un outil en effet
il s'agit pas bien sûr qu'un sondage
dc10 no kill légitimité pas ça aurait
arrangé christian genest mais
oui oui au fossat l'orangé reste à
savoir s'il a vraiment envie que ce soit
xavier bertrand son côté la wii on ne
sait pas pour vous mais je ne vais pas
bon donc
il s'agit d'un outil d'aidé à la
décision mais surtout si vous voulez il
faut bien partir de l'idée
qu'aujourd'hui les parties ça ne
représente pas grand chose voilà il n'y
a plus de corps intermédiaires en france
qu'une véritable légitimité et donc une
enquête surtout une enquête de ce type
ça permet de ça permet de connaître à
qui on a affaire est ce que vous savez
aujourd'hui par exemple moi j'aimerais
bien le savoir qui sont les électeurs
des gauches en france qui sont ils
qu'est ce qu'ils attendent comme leader
dans quel leader et surtout c'est le
noir absolu même chose pour les
électeurs par exemple écologistes on ne
le sait pas ceux qui se sont mobilisés
les 122 milles ce sont des sympathisants
c'est pas le peuple écologiste le peuple
écologiste s'était trois millions et
demi aux européennes des lecteurs donc
là ils ont un instrument j'aimerais
aussi beaucoup par exemple sur les
électeurs de marine le pen et du
rassemblement national saisir la
diversité des électorats d'url bon là au
moins pour la droite et le sandre on a
passé au scanner on sait ce qu'ils ont
en tête leur valeur ce qui pourrait les
mobiliser on sait comment ils se
positionnent par rapport à leur leader
qui ne sont pas des leaders naturels
mais qui sont des leaders qui ont tout
de même un certain poids mais la
notoriété reste en effet par exemple
pour valérie pécresse on voit bien elle
est très connue en ile de france un en
région mais elle n'est pas sortie avec
l'aco vide depuis deux ans de sa région
et donc elle a un déficit certainement
en région ça sera la même chose à gauche
d'ailleurs certainement pour un impôt
anne hidalgo ce sont des personnalités
encore très très très parisienne
jean-sébastien voulez puis on a derrière
sur les modes de sélection 1 on a une
idée serait dur congrès aux primaires
oui concret aux primaires mais vous avez
tout de même 50% un électeur sur deux
qui dit pourquoi pas une primaire de il
ya des gens 47% à 40 47 et 50 50 la
primaire intégral 47 l'autre ses
meilleurs éternel dans ses 70 ans en
pour le voir ah c'est ça voilà un et
donc ensuite qu'en voulant demandé de
juger la primaire il trouve de multiples
qualités à la primaire donc la primaire
ne doit pas être pour celles et ceux qui
vont décider complètement rejetés parce
que imaginez ils sont 82 mille
revendiquer les adhérents de l'air si
c'est eux qui décident eh bien ils
seront moins nombreux que ceux qui
auraient décidé de choisir le ou la
candidate écologiste en termes si vous
voulez d'affichage et de communication
je ne trouve pas ça ils sont 82
lilladher de roncq il faudra une
primaire ouverte jean sébastien ferjou
certains ça c'est une autre question
mais je pense que pour le cool enquête
en question elle est très intéressante
et je le crois et je respecte tout à
fait le sérieux du travail à la fois
très laïque d'avis et de pascal
perrineau mais un outil ça n'est jamais
que ce qu'on en fait avec une pêche que
vous tapez sur la tête creusez votre
tombe ou faire les fondations
faire les fondations
vous faire les fondations qui je ne
souhaite pas non plus mais faire les
fondations d'une maison donc la question
ce n'est pas en soi la crédibilité
l'outil c'est qu'en fait la direction du
parti parce que le véritable art
politique c'est de savoir voir plus loin
c'est la dynamique c'est de dire
aujourd'hui les gens pensent ça mais
j'anticipe que demain ils penseront
autre chose c'est d'être capable de dire
je sais pas en septembre octobre 2007
aujourd'hui les sondages ne disent que
les électeurs veulent alain juppé mais
j'anticipe que in fine et quand il y
aura une cristallisation ça ne sera plus
alain juppé que les électeurs voudront
parce que tout est dans la
cristallisation et on sait parfaitement
que ces dernières années plus ça va et
plus les gens se décident dans les tous
derniers jours d'où les surprises
d'ailleurs parfois parce que les
sondages c'est pas qu'ils mesurent mal
et chose c'est qu'ils ne peuvent pas
faire dire aux gens ce que les gens eux
mêmes n'ont pas encore tranché dans leur
tête je pense que là la faiblesse du
parti et cécile le prenais je ne dis pas
qu enfin on ne sait pas mais parce qu'il
décide est là cette semaine cécile le
prenez comme l'alpha et l'oméga de ce
qui se passera dans quatre mois dans
cinq mois je pense qu au point ils en
sont ils devraient assumer une primaire
sauvage qu'est ce qu'on en a à faire une
certaine manière possible non mais pas
non mais pas institutionnaliser jabba
écoutez vous voulez faire campagne faire
campagne
trash rade en vie parce que qu'est ce
qui va se passer la réalité c'est que en
l'état personne ne sait n'est capable
d'avoir une idée du champ politique
l'effet papillon qui peut partir d'eric
zemmour eric zemmour fragilise style
plus marine le pen fragile this plus un
candidat ait l'air éventuel eric zemmour
ouvre-t-il d'un seul coup un espace à
une droite qui n'y croyaient plus
vraiment et qui se résigner ou une
partie de la droite qui se résignent mm
macro parce que justement il risque de
faire chuter et d'empêcher marine le pen
d'être au second tour ça justement l'art
politique et là c'est d'essayer de se
projeter et d'anticiper mais pour
l'instant on n'y est pas alors on a
essayé je vais demander à mario guillot
de nous rejoindre sur ce plateau de
sondés enfin de poser la question où
parlementaire bonsoir marion bienvenus
voilà est-ce que est ce qu'il choisisse
xavier bertrand valérie pécresse ou
michel barnier on est resté sur les
trois principaux respectivement nous
avons profité du séminaire les
républicains qui a été organisée ce
matin au sénat avec les députés et les
sénateurs pour glaner quelques
informations et à ce jour sans surprise
sur les six candidats en lice trois se
démarque chez les parlementaires xavier
bertrand valérie pécresse et michel
barnier mais de quels soutiens
bénéficie-t-il exactement des trois
candidats michel bernis et celui qui se
déclarer le plus tard c'était le 26 août
et pour son équipe il est en train
justement de rattraper son retard sur
ses deux concurrents indirects
aujourd'hui il est soutenu par 31
sénateurs et 26 députés
valérie pécresse ça et bien selon ses
proches soutiens la présidente de la
région ile de france est suivi par une
cinquantaine de parlementaires de droite
répartis de la façon suivante une
vingtaine de députés une trentaine de
sénateurs cinq sénateurs ont d'ailleurs
étaient désignés hier orateurs de
valérie pécresse pour aller porter la
bonne parole un peu partout en france
xavier bertrand qui divise un peu plus
en vie puisque certains parlementaires
disent vouloir un candidat qui respecte
les règles et xavier bertrand qui n'est
plus encarté chez les républicains et
qui ne veut pas se soumettre à une
primaire pose problème mais selon les
décomptes datant de début septembre ils
allaient soutien d'une cinquantaine de
parlementaires 26 députés 26 sénateurs
on le voit donc pour chacun des
candidats le volume de soutien etc
allemand identique il reste en tout cas
une petite centaine de parlementaires
être encore indécis certains attendent
les orientations qui sont prises ce week
end lors du congrès pour se positionner
et c'est peut-être christian jacob qui
résume le mieux l'ambiance actuelle hier
le président du parti a déclaré je cite
s'il y avait un candidat naturel on
n'aurait pas besoin de toutes ces
procédures se serait déjà réglée et
effectivement du côté du parlement aucun
candidat ne tue le match et on a pu
entendre aujourd'hui des petites phrases
comme aucun ne me fait rêver aucun de me
faire rêver effectivement ça serait ça
serait plus simple et ça merci marion a
tout à leur excellent on retrouve pour
notre second débat consacré aux aux 40
ans du du tgv aucun d'eux me fait rêver
effectivement vous l'avez vous l'avez
dit les uns et les autres dans dans
votre analyse moi ce que je retiens
quand même c est ce que vous diriez sa
jean-sébastien vers une mini percée
barnier c'est ce qu'on ressent aussi
dans le sondage c'est ce que je me
disais twitter donc c'est aussi aussi
s'afficher les parlementaires et donc
aussi chez les sympathisants c'est de
toute façon il ya mes sympathisants et
après il ya la droite d'en haut en
quelque sorte de ce que souhaite le
parti je pense que le parti en tout cas
un certain nombre de dirigeants du parti
non pas une passion débordante à l'idée
on l'a bien vu d'organiser par exemple
une primaire qui légitime et légitimera
une candidature qui venaient de
l'extérieur du parti qu'elle soit celle
de xavier battront ils ne pas y aller ou
celle de valérie pécresse qu'on a un
laurent wauquiez laurent wauquiez
annonçant c'est celui qui est le plus
proche du centre de gravité de
l'électeur à droite après un problème de
crédibilité parce mais il a su en tirer
les conclusions ça n'est pas parce que
il s'est mis en retrait il remonte assez
fortement dans les angles les enquêtes
de popularité auprès de l'électorat de
droite depuis cette mise en retrait
qu'il va accepter n'importe qui comme
tant diable ce que vous imaginez bien
que pour lui il peut dire facilement
c'est perdu pour 2022 mais il ya 2027
donc autant éviter que quelqu'un vient
de me piquer le mistigri inscrit sa
rancune pour xavier quand vous regardez
tout ça quand vous regardez tout ça mis
bout-à-bout vous voyez quand même et la
remontée très rapide michel barnier sur
le nombre de parlementaires quand même
en creux le partage en est à mon sens en
train d'imaginer une hypothèse michel
barnier était par ailleurs est en train
d'essayer de récupérer le positionnement
fillonniste ça il le dit je fais en
sourdine y compris en récupérant des
équipes d'accord de françois fillon
valérie damidot jean sébastien ferjou
c'est vrai que dans notre enquête il ya
des éléments qui corroborent ce que vous
dites il est distancé sur le critère de
la bonne opinion mais c'est celui ci je
vais philippe juvin de coder de faire
coter qui est très peu connu c'est celui
entre valérie pécresse et bertrand qui a
le plus petit nombre de mauvaises
opinions et si je rebondis sur ce qui
vient d'être dit aucun ne fait rêver ça
pourrait être lui comme il a le plus
petit nombre de mauvaises opinions qui
serait le plus petit dénominateur commun
deuxièmement il c'est le seul qui
arrivent a devancé à xavier bertrand sur
une dimension qui est il est capable de
bien représenter la france à l'étranger
la stature présidentielle dans une
campagne même dans une précampagne mais
dans une primaire compte et dans le rang
et puis il ya les bénéfices de son
absence du champ politique pendant
quelques heures et oui il est en retrait
car il a plus de chemin à faire pour
reconstruire un lien avec les français
mais c'est celui qui arrive quasiment en
tête il est à un point d'eux et bertrand
sûr il est capable de bien gérer une
crise et qu'est ce que c'est que ce
quinquennat c'était un cetain c'est un
enchaînement jamais vu de crise on y est
certes distancé par bertrand et pécresse
mais c'est peut-être plus qui connaît
cette amorce de dynamique et puis chose
c'est intéressant je suis intéressé de
voir que entre les trois c'est très très
équilibré sur les parlementaires en 2016
il y avait un il y avait un candidat qui
était distancée dans les enquête
d'opinion mais qui avait beaucoup de
parlementaires c'était françois fillon
bongay sur michel barnier pascal
perrineau en effet michel barnier je le
disais d'entrée existe avec les deux qui
pour l'instant mais son candidat depuis
plus longtemps il existe il existe sur
la dimension internationale il existe
aussi sur la capacité
à incarner les valeurs
la droite et du centre ils sont un
positionnement de récupération d'une
partie de la torah fillon est ce que
leur école le sondage ne permet pas
d'aller d'aller là pour l'instant on a
des données qui montrent comment les
électeurs qui avaient voté françois
fillon votre est aujourd'hui parmi les
candidats on s'aperçoit que celui qui
capte le mieux l'électorat ça reste
xavier bertand d'accord ensuite valérie
pécresse et ensuite michel barnier mais
là le jeu s'est subitement resserré
puisque le jeu c'est maintenant une
affaire interne au parti un aidant les
parties je ne crois pas qu'il s'agisse
de rêver hein on dit aucun ne fait rêver
bon on rêve assez peu dans les parties
peut être pas assez d'ailleurs justement
donc c'est le seul tout de même qui
parmi les grands candidats à la carte du
parti c'est quelqu'un qui est dans
l'organisation depuis l'âge de 16 ans il
est rentré en politique extrêmement tôt
et il n'a pas cette image que l'on
entend de temps en temps dans les
couloirs les traîtres à les traîtres
c'est ceux qui ont quitté le navire le
navire rpr où le navire le navire des
républicains donc
oui c'est un homme qui certainement au
centre de gravité du parti sachant que
quand on écoute les différentes
sensibilités du parti si vous voulez les
leers et c'est bien que ce soit au
pluriel parce que voilà c'est un parti
beaucoup plus pluriel qu'on veut bien le
croire et quand on regarde christian
jacob voilà il cherche à fédérer des
sensibilités qui vont de julien aubert à
des sensibilités qui sont des
sensibilités en fait beaucoup plus
centriste en passant plus j'appellerais
ça plutôt à canal historique de
sensibilité gaullienne sur lequel michel
barnier a véritablement un impact et
dernier point sur michel barnier comment
dire la fonction présidentielle c'est
l'incarnation et c'est important de
faire président est il physiquement il
fait président voilà c'est un argument
celui qui peut modérer l'enthousiasmé
est trop lisse trop techno sur ça aussi
on dit souvent ça aussi de monsieur ben
oui mais ce n'est pas là-dessus que
voilà sur des critères qui sont qui sont
classiques non je vais modérer
l'enthousiasmé parce qu'il me semble que
ils bénéficient d'une prime un peu
paradoxal c'est la prime de justement
l'inconnu c'est à dire que très peu de
personnes ont une mauvaise opinion de
lui parce qu'ils ne connaissent pas
c'est à dire qu'il est le moins exposé
pour l'instant détroit donc ils
bénéficient d'un doute pourquoi bas
effectivement de raisonnement qui se
fonde sur la stature sur son apparence
sur le fait qu'on a largement vaguement
compris qu'il avait joué un rôle dans le
bric site voyez mais pour l'instant il
ne s'est pas vraiment mis face aux
français chose que valérie pécresse va
engager tout de suite parce que elle va
jouer les sondages elle c'est très clair
sa stratégie de communication est en
place elle va jouer les médias et les
sondages donc elle va jouer l'opinion
publique qui est peut-être une stratégie
intéressante il me semble pour 2011 jean
sébastien ferjou je suis d'accord avec
l'ancien groupe a probablement michel
barnier bénéficie du fait que les moins
clivant tout simplement parce qu'il sait
moi a lancé quoi qu'il a quand même
marqué très fortement les esprits avec
son sa proposition d'un moratoire sur
l'immigration est très surprenant venant
de lui sa proposition sur la
modification de la hiérarchie du droit
européen finalement en disant on va
modifier la constitution pour ne plus
dépendre sur les sujets dont on
considérer qu'il est vraiment la
souveraineté exclusive française du
droit de faire assez dans la ligne de ce
rapprochement avec wauquiez dont vous
parliez tout à l'heure en tout cas sur
les jeunes et je pense qu'il est en
train de jouer quand je vous parlais de
l'électorat fillon s'était pas des
électrodes des électeurs fillonniste
celle des plus de récupérer une partie
des réseaux fillon l'esc est certain
c'est que vous ne gagnez jamais quand
vous n'avez que votre coeur des lecteurs
ça c'est la configuration finalement
dernières européennes laurent wauquiez
françois-xavier bellamy mépris dans
l'autre sens vous jamais vous ne gagnez
jamais contre nice en votre carte
d'électeur à skis évoqué pascal
perrineau sur les traîtres alors qu'ils
aient un qualificatif qu'on peut ne pas
partager enfin bref en ce qui concerne
xavier bertrand comme valérie pécresse
mais le coeur de l'électorat
il l'a vécu comme ça et puis y'a quand
même le sujet de la sincérité alors vous
allez me dire toute nouvelle relative
puisque michel barnier lui même qui
était très pro-européens fini par
adopter un point de vue presque
souverainiste enfin on se souvient quand
même et laurent wauquiez l'a souligné
saad et l été dernier que comment se
fait-il que des gens qui ont claqué la
porte du parti en ayant des hauts le
coeur sur la droitisation face à sow de
droitisation aujourd'hui que s'est il
passé entre 2017 alors juge xavier
bertrand répond là dessus xavier berger
toit du second tour exactement et xavier
bertrand est a été beaucoup plus
constant dans sa posture film valérie
pécresse je pense qu'elle pourra
beaucoup se présenter auprès l'opinion
publique le coeur des lecteurs à droite
il considéra que malgré tout elle a
claqué la porte avec elle a trahi on va
écouter christian jacob
qui réagit finalement au sondage qu'il a
commandé c'était hier juste après le
bureau politique du parti elle quand on
les interroge est-ce que quelle est la
procédure selon vous la meilleure ce qui
vient en tête très largement c'est le
congrès à 60 % ce qui correspond
de toute façon un choix de notre
électorat de droite qui aiment l'ordre
et qui ne veut pas de divisions parce
que le division nous ont ramené depuis
dix ans être dans l'opposition et on l'a
bien vu au moment des régionales il ya
une envie de gagner dans notre électorat
est très forte est ce que quand même le
temps là la question de la temporalité
on dit le titre de notre débat c'est le
feuilleton sans fin pascal perrineau ça
c'est quand même une pierre dans le
jardin de christian jacob ou ne pas
avoir réussi à faire émerger un candidat
plus tôt alors tout est relatif parce
que vous savez quand vous reprenez le
moment où la droite a choisi ses
candidats en général c'est en novembre
c'était le cas pour
chirac c'était le cas pour sarkozy
c'était le cas pour filles voyez donc on
a tendance parfois envoyés à
reconstruire mais la grande dit j'avais
posé moins d'un connus pour leur tour
chirac pour sa cousine mais mais mais
vous voyez
c'était même la dernière fois voilà
c'est le 24 novembre je moi que françois
fillon ait choisi donc voilà il faut pas
non plus aller trop vite en besogne
parce que la droite ce serait quelque
peu épuisé mais la grande différence
c'est que les règles du jeu étaient
claires le peuple de droite et du centre
savez avec quelles modalités il allait
choisir le problème c'est que là on
effacer temps et ils savent toujours pas
il faut savoir bientôt et on voit c'est
tout à fait ça on voit dans nos enquêtes
une véritable fébrilité j'avais noté un
verbatim récents un acteur de droite
nous dit en septembre 2016 tout était
clair ont voté au mois de novembre ont
voté pour le futur vainqueur de
l'élection présidentielle c'était ça
aussi le commentaires médiatiques compte
tenu de l'affaiblissement de françois
hollande et la capacité de marine le pen
à voir transformer l'essai des élections
un jeu lalla on en septembre 2021 il ya
cette fébrilité qu'elle quel jeu qu'est
le chemin dans un contexte où vous en
parliez tout à l'heure jean sébastien il
ya ce trublion zemmour qui arrive à
avoir une sorte de socle électoral
hybride où il arrive à prendre de
l'électorat de droite traditionnelle
âgées qui est fatigué du déclin du pays
et qui se reconnaît dans les hauteurs du
du suicide français le koteka son
adresse qu'on vote pour cassandre ça
n'arrive pas souvent mais en tout cas il
ya cet attrait là et puis il prend aussi
du côté de l'électorat et rennes
traditionn qui est sûre celui là que
cette partie que marine le pen comme dit
de manière un peu triviale eric zemmour
est nulle et qu'elle ne pourra pas
gagner l'élection présidentielle dont il
ya aussi cette ébriété elle s'inscrit
dans un contexte et un écosystème de
droite d'un côté du pays est
complètement
droitiser jamais autant de français ne
se sont positionnés à droite de l'autre
il ya ce chemin qui n'est pas encore
décidée alors crise un jacob 10 au
bureau politique dimanche ça sera fait
il faut je pense qu'à espérer alors sur
l'hypothèse zemmour le figaro affirmait
qu' ils envisageaient de participer à la
primaire informations de la rédaction de
public sénat que je vous livre à
l'instant il y a dans la modification
des statuts à l'air qui sera soumise au
vote des militants samedi cette phrase
je voulais lire une instance de contrôle
nommé par le bureau politique sur
proposition du président du mouvement
sera chargée de la validation du corps
électoral de la recevabilité des
candidatures au regard notamment de leur
compatibilité aux valeurs de la droite
et du centre et de la sincérité des
résultats est ce que ça peut être une
arme anti zemmour aux primaires ça jean
sébastien ferjou mais bien sûr mais
c'est pour ça qu'il peut y avoir de
stabilité l'électorat de droite peut
effectivement être assez mécontents
parce que le grand paradoxe est qu'il
n'ya jamais eu autant de demandes de
droite quasiment non sur les dernières
élections présidentielles et jamais la
droite où ce parti et les républicains
qui reste quand même le parti au
gouvernement mais était aussi peu
capables d'y répondre mais bien sûr que
ils vont essayer de faire en sorte
d'éviter eric zemmour mais à l'arrivée
les électeurs je pense qu'ils le
ressentent un peu c'est pour ça que je
vous disais tout à l'heure au point ils
ont sont tout aussi bien il pourrait
risquer une primaire sauvage mais quand
je dis une primaire sauvage c'est pas
institutionnel c'est à dire des écoutes
et voulait être candidat soyez candidat
que le meilleur l'emporté puis on verra
bien en janvier en février en revanche
contre vous par tonne n'est pas celui
qui ne se retirait pas qui nous ferait
perdre parce que ça leur valeur si
jamais il organiser une primaire mais je
ne crois pas une seconde ça va leur
coûter beaucoup d'argent pour finalement
pas grand chose parce que encore une
fois justement ça n'est pas départagé
est pris dans l'autre sens ce type de
choses là ça suggère quoi ça suggère que
de toute façon c'est du tripatouillage
et que de toute façon la tête du parti
est en train de plus ou moins agir pour
favoriser le candidat qui l'arrangent
même l' enquête doit être perçue comme
ça je vous dis pas qu'elle a été faite
de cette manière là mais elle peut être
perçue comme ça juste de l'extérieur par
un certain nombre d'électeurs et donc je
vous dis bizarrement puisqu'ils n'ont
pas été capables avec la direction du
parti ils ont rien fait pendant le
quinquennat d'avant ils sont par le
construit son parent a construit pendant
celui là non plus autant qu'ils assument
et finalement dans la logique d'une
primaire à l'américaine tiers qui n'a
rien à voir d'un point de vue
institutionnel on n'a pas besoin de
représenter l'alsace pour éviter
qu'elles soient noyés par le poids
démographique de l'île de france en
revanche dans une primaire américaine
vous jouez le calendrier
la consolidation la cristallisation des
candidatures jusqu'à deux mois avant
l'élection est ce que cette instance de
contrôle les détails retrouvez
d'ailleurs sur le site un publicsenat.fr
est-ce que laëtitia c'est pas aussi une
sorte d'aveu de faiblesse se dire on se
donne les moyens
l'hexagone qui rentre dans le jeu bah
oui c'est ça oui c'est vrai c'est vrai
non non c'est vrai en plus bon je sais
pas si tous les français vont comprendre
effectivement à quoi va servir encore
une fois c'est toujours la même question
enfin c'est à dire que soyons
transparents est ce qu'il faut je pense
qu'il faut se positionner de façon ferme
oui ou non à l'ouverture de cette
primaire à eric zemmour et en et gagnera
le débat public et gagnera il me semble
quand même que je ya une question qui
reste quand même au terme de ce débat et
si le candidat de la droite était
emmanuel macron
il a ils s'écharpent depuis des mois et
des mois et ici le candidat de la droite
c'était emmanuel macron alors c'est vrai
on valises une enquête la semaine
dernière pour sud radio on voit que une
question toute simple à ce que chacune
séparée de ses personnalités suivantes
incarne bien ou mal la droite il arrive
en troisième position d'ailleurs xavier
bertrand d'ailleurs valérie pécresse
alors au prénom sont des français à
droite il n'en peut plus a mais il a un
socle extrêmement nettes et puis ça se
construit d'un récit il a fait les
réformes que le peuple de droite avaient
rêvé de faire il il fait aussi président
il incarne il incarne l'ordre et la
sécurité même s'il est faible sur ce
dimanche soir il ya quand même un
problème dans son équation
électorale il incarne aussi - mais il
incarne une partie de la gauche et le
peuple droite ne peut pas accepter
quelqu'un qui soit peut-être de ce point
de vue là même nom il arrive à capter
mais il peut faire un autre calcul le
peuple de droite alors après
consciemment ou inconsciemment parce que
parfois on a des raisonnements des coups
ont fait enfin bref de l'autopsié en
quelque sorte des raisonnements entre
les gens le font sens encore comme un
pays peut se dire il peut se dire
finalement emmanuel macron c'est quand
même pas anne hidalgo s'est pas non plus
comme une quand on devait choisir entre
françois hollande et nicolas sarkozy ou
donc à la nuit ton pourrait vivre avec
emmanuel macron si c'est pour désigner
un nouveau chiraquien qui ne se fasse on
fait semblant d'être hyper à droite
pendant la campagne et puis qu'on a rien
derrière est-ce que c'est prendre un si
grand risque que ça de rester avec les
manuels macron et de miser sur une vraie
reconstruction de la droite pour le coup
d'après parce que je t'ai pour un
chiraquien entre guillemets je vous
demande et la perception que les gens
peuvent en avoir qui nous fasse rien et
qu'il nous faut dans l'opposition pour
quinze ans on a déjà essayé y compris
allez on va prendre trois minutes de
plus dans d'or dans ce débat pour parler
quand même de nicolas sarkozy nicolas
sarkozy qui qui pour l'instant n'a pas
choisi il était à calais hier sur les
terres de xavier bertrand il lui a dit
son amitié bon on peut parler de service
minimum est ce qui pourrait de si peu
choisir de ne pas choisir pascal
perrineau sarko écouter ce qu'il ce
qu'il a dit à calais est tout de même
certes c'est un peu le service minimum
c'est un peu plus cher
c'est un peu plus que le service minimum
en effet il aimerait bien pouvoir
contribuer au retour des siens et de la
droite au pouvoir même si les liens avec
l'actuel président sont loin des liens
d'être des loin des liens mais qu'est ce
qui vous fait dire que c'est un peu plus
que le service minimum je ne sais pas
vous savez sarkozy parfois il fait un
service qui est en dessous du minimum
avec les siens et là étant donné les
relations qui ne sont pas des relations
intimes avec bertrand je trouve que
voilà il a fait un peu plus que le
service minimum et il a envoyé à celui
qui se dégage tout de même comme étant
aujourd'hui le seul candidat de droite
capable de récupérer une majorité de
l'électorat fillon s'il y en a qu'un
aujourd'hui c'est xavier bertrand de
récupérer la majorité l'électorat fillon
tous les autres on récupère moins de 50%
mais pour gagner et pour passer au
second tour ça ne suffit pas parce que
faut récupérer ce qui en est fait
aujourd'hui choisissent encore macron
mais peuvent avoir un doute sur emmanuel
kron le ralliement comme l'a dit
frédéric s'est fait sur des thématiques
économiques mais sur le régalien si vous
voulez le emmanuel macron n'est pas le
candidat de ses droits thomas crown east
sur le régalien il ya toujours un doute
il fait des efforts le président mais il
ya toujours un doute et puis il ya les
15% à peu près de cet électorat fillon
qui aujourd'hui sont vers marine le pen
donc j'allais dire on est au début du
travail de reconquête
mais y en a qui partent avec un socle
qui est un soc majoritaire qui en a un
xavier bertrand les autres sont tous
même plus loin dans la construction de
ce travail de reconquête qui va être un
combat redoutable et un mot de
conclusion ferry d'habiles enquête c'est
l'ifop qui là qu'il l'a sorti le le rôle
de nicolas sarkozy j'aurais sur ce thème
de fin comment vous l'imaginez c'est
hors de france est une statue du
commandeur à droite dans ne peut plus de
droite qui a quand même acte et son
retrait de la vie politique il a été
battu en 2012 a été battu par son propre
peuple si je puis dire en 2016 c'est
quelque chose qui marche c'est vrai que
ce qu'il a dit a dit xavier bertrand
s'était fort un bon ministre ok il dit
quand même un des rares qui l'a soutenu
quand il a été en difficulté et quand on
sait qu'il ya des sarkozy je ne donnerai
pas de noms qui sont peu bienveillants
vis-à-vis d'eux et bertrand ça un petit
peu contrebalancé savez ces graines qui
peut être une sorte de faiseurs de rois
à droite mais faux pas de rennes ii roi
ou de reine bien sûr mais il faut pas
oublier qu auprès de l'ensemble des
français il ya aussi un côté qui peut
être pouvoir à l'égard de nicolas
sarkozy une et une présidentielle c'est
son camp au premier tour et élargir au
second merci beaucoup merci à tous les
trois doivent participer à ce débat